i got to ask you your
opinion because i have a controversial
opinion about this matter oh [ __ ] okay
so the controversial i am i am a part of
the crowd that believes
that machine gun kelly won the battle
against eminem okay
now i'll give you my reasoning and then
i want you to give me your thoughts on
it
i feel like
mgk
should not have stood a chance right i
feel like the fact that anybody even
the fact is even a question to me means
mgk one now lyrically did eminem rap
better on kill shot of course he did but
in my opinion
the better dis record was the mgk dish
record
and i feel like
eminem is
probably the greatest mc of all time
when it comes to putting words together
i mean
and so to me it was like the fact that
mgk who's not known to get down like
that the fact we even anyone's even
having a debate about it means he won
right how do you feel
um
[Music]
i feel like
when a guy is
you know playing basketball and
they playing the chicago boys tonight
and you got to guard jordan mm-hmm
and you do all right against him and you
shut him down and he usually score
50 at night but tonight he scores 35
i think it's a win-win for you
so i just think that
i'm just glad i think i'm just glad that
mdk did all he did all right man he did
good he should
he should applaud himself he made him a
good rap man that's why i feel i'm like
yo man i'm saying but get get out of
here man before
you get mad he got in and out
man
and i'm i'm actually and i was very
happy that
that he pulled that out of m at this
area's career yeah because i was like yo
eminem just dropped a dis record was it
2019 yeah 2018.
like this is amazing
like the fact that like he was at least
able like the fact eminem responded was
even if he got washed it's like bro and
responded to you you're on the artwork
to the song right right like you know
what i'm saying like
to be honest you ain't think you had it
in him did you
who mgk before he did that you ain't
thinking yeah
i'm i'm listening to his previous [ __ ]
i mean i would say this about mgk i am
pretty
i would say i'm like pretty friendly
with with kel's and i feel like he
doesn't he ain't no sucker i mean
i knew i knew mgk wasn't a sucker
i i first i know he ended up like i know
i know [ __ ] that you [ __ ] with from
cleveland and he's an amazing performer
and lyrically he he does his thing and
so when i heard the the rap devil [ __ ] i
was like oh i mean you know okay this is
cool like
but i was like when i saw the artwork to
kill shot i was like oh it's [ __ ]
it's about to get ugly
it's about to get ugly but then i came
away from kill shots saying ah okay i
don't know if you know and to me the
fact i even did that was like okay well
like like you said it was like kind of
like
you know it was a little bit more un a
little closer than people expected